thank you very much for your time you
know you're very busy guy and a very
important one in supply chain string so
thank you very much for your time okay
we have a lot of questions but we have
limited time so I'm going to sell it
first 10 one more has done some efforts
in innovating and since your
transportation your background is a very
deep in transportation effort I know
that you are you've been related with a
wave with the web project right which is
a walmart advanced vehicle experience I
have a few questions related to that is
this concept vehicle and is it is it
close to be a reality it is it going to
be a reality for sure does walmart right
now knows that it can be a reality is it
feasible to manufacture these these kind
of trucks and how we're going to be
seeing these trucks in the in the roads
in the short term the other one is up
how how does this vehicle fit into the
into the sustainability strategy for
Walmart and now how do you see the
training and under swift for for truck
drivers from old trucks to these kind of
trucks new trucks right right okay let
me back up first let me talk the
sustainability piece first then I'll
talk about one about where we stand from
the standpoint of using the wave truck
and whether we'll see the wave truck on
the roads and then last i'll talk about
driver training does that answer your
three questions can add a last one sure
they're up do you plan on small comments
for for these kind of trucks because i
saw a huge one yeah this lever one yeah
but do you plan to have a small format
since you're going since you're moving
to that nano chance and for some new
small formats for one okay yeah we'll
talk about type of trucks first off from
a sustainability standpoint we were
challenged by our CEO in 2005
to double our fleet efficiency over the
next 10 years okay so that's a challenge
he just threw out he didn't consult with
anyone he just made a bold statement in
relationship to some of the activities
that we had done post-hurricane Katrina
so we've been on a mission over the last
10 years to attempt to double our fleet
efficiency now we look at fleet
efficiency from the standpoint of cases
moved and gallons of fuel burned that's
how we measured and right now here in
2014 now 2015 we're about ninety percent
more efficient than where we were in
2005 now the issue is how have we gotten
there okay primarily it's been through a
number of different activities outside
of the truck okay not about the truck
but about activities so it's about how
we load the trucks how we r out the
trucks how the drivers behave how the
drivers focus what we're focusing now on
are the things we can do around the
physical truck that's why you've seen
the wave truck the white truck was
really a partnership with a company
called Peterbilt and redevelop that
concept truck with Peterbilt to try to
really do something radically different
that's actually the fourth generation of
truck working with them we had trucks
before this one but because this one
looked so unique this one ended up
getting a lot of press now that truck
was designed and the air tests have
shown that it's about fifteen or twenty
percent more aerodynamic than a normal
truck you would see out on the highway
today so there's something there will
you see it on the highway today no well
you see it next year no will you see it
in three or four years probably not what
you will see is different learnings from
that truck that truck is a hybrid so
that truck is
running off of batteries we actually use
a turbine you know it yeah we actually
use a turbine engine to power the
batteries and then all the componentry
is slaved off of those batteries so
that's how the thing actually operates
the beauty about a turbine engine is it
is basically fuel neutral you can run
lots of different fuels through so
that's what makes it fairly unique now
the problems with why you will not see
that wave truck out on the highway or it
does not meet do t specifications so the
US Department of Transportation there's
issues with the light design there's
issues with the fiberglass that it's
built with there's issues with the way
the windows are designed there's issues
that there's no rearview mirrors it's
all cameras so there's lots of things
that from a US Department of
Transportation standpoint don't meet the
safety guidelines that would cause it to
be approved but we're already learning
from that truck and being able to apply
those learnings to other trucks as are
the manufacturers so from that
standpoint it's working now back to
driver training we know today that
probably there's a fuel efficiency
improvement of approximately twenty or
thirty percent that's totally controlled
by driver behavior now so how drivers
behave how they choose to drive is a
huge issue for us so we will continue to
focus on training our drivers in sin
tising our drivers engaging our drivers
giving our drivers those visible tools
like on the screen in front of them
showing them exactly what their MPG is
all the time to change their behavior to
focus on those kind of things because we
know they control a lot of that last
small format stores how does this change
we are testing other type vehicles other
type of delivery mechanisms for smaller
format access points
could be a store it could be a drop-off
point it could be a delivery vehicle
clearly to go to someone's home we're
not going to take a 50 you know 53-foot
tractor-trailer rig to someone's home so
we've got smaller vehicles that we're
testing right now some are temperature
controlled some or not we're also
playing with that depending on what
we're delivering in hell we're having a
lot of those things in the works hope to
see them indonesia thank you yes so my
question Chris is when expanding into
new geographies of market what are the
key supply chain and logistics
challenges that warmer faces and key if
you can give us an example where it
worked well and wet it did not work well
and what is the learning if it did not
work with I've got tons of examples
where it didn't work well a lot of it
you've got to tailor the supply chain
solution to the market conditions let me
give you it let me give you a very good
example think about your India no one
here well your Venezuela think about the
geography of chilly when Walmart first
went into Chile you've got to think
about the geography of that country okay
Chile is as north-south tall as the
United States is east-west wide but yet
Chile is only about a hundred miles wide
you know long tall country we have
stores down in the south in the
Patagonia type area as well as storms up
north and the more metropolitan areas
our supply chain solution has to take
into account that type of geography we
have people that have been very involved
in the geography of the UK and then come
over to the United States and don't
realize especially as you get into the
western part of the United States the
openness of the environment in the
distance that you have between
distribution centers and stores there's
also labor components when we first
walked into China we wanted to put in a
lot of mechanization solutions that we
use in the United States the labor
components in
china didn't justify that level of
mechanization nor did they down in
Mexico it made more sense to put labor
against the solution rather than put
machines against the solution so those
are all of the things you've got to look
at the other challenge we've had
recently is done in Brazil Brazil from a
transportation perspective did not have
hours of service regulations they just
instituted those this year and the hours
of service regulations in Brazil are now
more stringent than the United States
that causes you to have to have a
different solution from a transportation
standpoint and a lot more investment in
transportation because of the hours of
service that's true if there's an
enforcement of the hours of service
because it's brand-new no one's
enforcing the laws yet so if you go poor
and expensive solution into something
that's not being enforced you've got to
be careful you can put yourself at a
competitive disadvantage so those are
the things you've got to work with in
every market we had all kind of
solutions and successes and countries we
had all kind of misses in countries
Japan was another great example because
do in Japan there's such a level of
distributor model or one group cells to
another group cells to another group
cells to another group then finally
sells to the retailer trying to get in
and be a retailer going directly to the
producer has been very difficult because
of the structure in that market so
there's every market has its own unique
characteristics that answer your
question that's good very good Chuck
Chris my question is about small store
formats and the movement towards urban
populations I know that walmart has
tested some of the small format stores
in Chicago and I used to live in chicago
and i know it's a very planned out grid
street network and i was wondering what
how is walmart looking at cities like
Boston that are not laid out on a grid
that they require very a different
approach how was walmart trying to
tackle those kinds of markets I would
tell you our strategy of metropolitan
markets which is really what you're
talking about or dense urban markets our
strategy has kind of been evolving over
time for example you talked about
Chicago do you know where the
presidential towers are in Chicago
high-rise apartments yes we've got a
neighborhood market at the base of four
large towers now those four large towers
represent 60,000 people at the base of
those large towers we put a neighborhood
market now that's working pretty good
the problem is there's no dock there's
limited receiving hours delivery hours
and the volume that's going through that
operation is a very large so it's
presented a unique set of challenges for
us as we've looked at other dense urban
markets some urban markets like New York
City we haven't been allowed to put
stores in the municipality and
everything else with the zoning laws and
everything else we haven't overcome that
so I think what we'll end up doing is
looking at different solutions for
different markets I think what we may
end up doing is a lot more access points
or delivery points in a lot of these
more dense urban markets we clearly will
have much smaller square footage a--'s
of stores or retail locations in the
dense market for us is going to be
different logistics solutions than what
we're only used to because again just
like we talked about in other markets
you're not going to take a 53-foot
tractor-trailer rig into downtown
Chicago or downtown Boston or downtown
New York City you've got have a
different delivery vehicle a different
frequency in a different solution and so
those are the different solutions were
playing with right now
Thanks you betcha I guess my question is
about the work that was murdered during
Hurricane Katrina yeah what I wanted to
ask was what have been the learnings
from that humanitarian work that was
done for Walmart what are what could be
the possible takeaways for the other
agencies in fact you guys were the first
to reach the people Fame I and other
agencies that followed you there and the
third part is that is there an effort to
institutionalize such things either
independently in the geographies that
you work or in partnership with actual
relief agencies good let me start with
the first question instead of the third
and then you may have to help me with
the second question okay in terms of
what we learned from Katrina probably
the biggest thing we learned is that we
can be a very positive force in those
times of crisis and one of the things
you talked about that we were in there
in many cases before the relief agencies
well we were and in a lot of ways we
were because it was easier for us we
already have a supply chain we already
have a retail store we already have
distribution centers we already run
trucks up and down those same roads so
in some cases it was much easier for us
to respond to the crisis than it was say
the National Guard or the reserves or
FEMA they had to first mobilize well
every day were mobilized so we were
already in that position some of the
learnings that we developed from that
though was that we've got to be in a lot
better synchronized position with the
local affiliates the local organizations
for example we found in Katrina that
lots of times you would have road
closures or road blockages and we
wouldn't be able to get goods to our
stores well in many cases those mayor's
or in the case of Louisiana those parish
leaders wanted us to open the store but
we couldn't open the store for that
local mayor because that parish leader
would
allow the road to be opened so we
encountered a lot of those kind of
obstacles that we determined early on
that we've got to have a much better
line of sight a much better process to
get through some of that bureaucratic
situation that you get when you get all
of these different levels of
governmental authority that are imposing
their will on the situation so what we
ended up doing we already had an
emergency operation center but we really
took our Emergency Operations Center to
a whole new level post-katrina and what
we learned from that is that we need to
be connected as low as we can to every
operation center that there is out of
the field so in the case of Katrina we
need to be connected to Louisiana we
need to have direct communication with
the governor's office and all of the
people on the in the field on the ground
so that we can break through as much of
that red tape as possible we also
learned that we've got to connect with
the military so we are held a number of
summits some of those in Bentonville
with a lot of the leading military
authority for natural disasters to
figure out how they can actually use us
and we can use them for example with
Katrina we needed security turned out
then the government displaced a large
group of homeless people within a mile
of one of our food distribution centers
well that's sent up alarms because there
was a lot of unrest and a lot of people
weren't getting food fast enough could
you have a situation where they might
overrun our distribution center to get
at what we had there versus being a
controlled process so we've got to work
with the government to do those things
right and at times the government
actually through the guard can actually
help provide us security and protection
particularly with opening roads and
things like that so that we can do our
job and our job really is to distribute
product distribute food distribute
consumer goods one of the things we
found almost from a personal standpoint
a normalcy standpoint is it when
times of crisis like during Katrina
people want assurance people want a
sense of calmness well what we found is
in a lot of these crisis areas what they
really want and what the consumer wants
what people want is they want their
store open mm-hmm they want their store
of it because if the store is open then
there's that sense of I can get stuff i
can get water I can get batteries i can
get clothing but if their stores closed
it can cause a sense of pin and so so
often what the local authorities are
desperate for us to do is open stores
and keep stores supplied and keep the
lights on so that's the things we have
to do and we've got to work with the
municipalities from the standpoint of
power because usually what we've
established now is that after the local
security facilities and the local
hospital the first thing to get power is
the walmart store because it provides
that sense of normalcy for the community
now did I answer those questions or was
there one more in there are less a
second when I would rephrase it what
would you of your expectations be from
the actual relief agencies and such time
yeah and I think really when I think
about the military is particularly the
National Guard we need security we need
that level of security and support in
that instance that I told you we went
out as a company and hired private
security to ensure that our facility
wasn't overrun you just don't think
about that happening in the United
States but that was an that was a
genuine fear so we need the military to
help us with Road openings with security
and those type things and oh by the way
the military does that better than
anyone that's what they do well we found
during Katrina we were feeding the
military so during the Katrina situation
in a lot of cases the National Guard was
mobilized but the infrastructure to
support the guard wasn't mobilized so we
ended up providing food and feeding the
military those are some of those things
that we
do complementary to the things the
government can do also complimenting us
and so those are the things we've got to
do working together thank you you bet
you bet other questions Walmart said
that these years is deploying this past
2014 has employed plans to integrate
even more particularly on the supply
chain and it's it's been on the news all
over you want to ensure the efficiency
and some effectiveness that is lacking
on the supply chain how far is one more
planning to go on this integration and
how far how much control one more think
that it's needed for its operation to be
efficient this is right my first
question and I'm my second question but
it's not a question actually it's uh I
want to know this basically because I'm
an entrepreneur in supply chain and I
would like to know if you have an advice
for these for these suppliers or maybe
possible suppliers out there because
you're not you're not getting something
from your supplies it's something that
you want but it's not out there and
that's why you have to you have to look
and seek integration what is it that you
would like to see in your suppliers and
something that you you you don't find
out there right now okay first from the
vertical integration piece of the
question the only area is right now or
we're going vertical would be that when
we work extensively with our growers
okay from the standpoint of producing
TVs or laundry detergent things like
that we don't do that and we've not made
moves to get into
type of manufacturing but when it comes
to food and commodities things like
produce meat seafood we are working
directly with the growers and the
producers of the product and there's
multitude of reasons why when you work
directly with them you can control
quality when you work directly with them
you can also get a better cost situation
it's kind of what we were talking or I
was talking with an individual about
earlier in Central America with our
company called horde a fruity what we
are doing is buying up whole fields so
we assure that farmer if you will grow
your product in this manner we will buy
everything you produce and that gives
that grower that assurance that if they
make that investment then they're going
to sell their entire crop at a set price
so they have that level of assurance and
confidence that their financial model
will work so we are doing more and more
of that but that's the extent of the
vertical integration and then the last
piece of that vertical that I left out I
talked about price and quality but also
just product quantity we have a large
appetite with the size of the company we
need lots of product so the US consumer
in our case they want grapes you're
around they don't want grapes just when
they're being grown in the United States
they want strawberries as often as they
can get them they want blueberries as
often so a lot of that product becomes
globally sourced to complement the
growing seasons in South America from
our standpoint Chile Ecuador in all of
those areas sourced into the United
States so we have to get closer and
closer to the producer side but its
primary elephants
your second question was around as an
entrepreneur as I so far what we would I
want out of you probably the greatest
things innovation again we are
constantly looking for new products new
ideas new solutions new services that
consumers want what we've got to balance
is the fact that we've got this huge
appetite so if you're a small
entrepreneur and you bring an idea and
this level of scale Walmart wants this
scale so there's got to be a balancing
act that we do it in a manner that you
can be successful but at the same time
we can bring that new idea to market as
fast as possible so probably the
greatest thing would be innovation does
that answer your personal yeah very good
yes question regarding you go
technological change it doesn't happen
yeah what do you think will the shape of
this retailing industry in the next five
to ten years and how this all not
getting up for that change I think the
biggest thing I see from the standpoint
we talked earlier about constant changes
change going on is written the biggest
thing I see right now is actually the
speed of change so where as we've seen
change go on for by 26 years with the
company and testing and everything else
the speed of that change is happening a
lot faster today then I have ever seen
it I can only envision that it'll be
happening much faster when you're
sitting in my chair 26 years from now so
how we adapt to that speed capitalize on
that speed and how a large company can
be nimble to move fast as fast as an
entrepreneurial small company I think
that's our greatest challenge so how do
we move fast make decisions quick deploy
capital fast and keep up or accelerate
that the pace changes happening right
now is our biggest challenge an answer
yet pretty good Chuck we have time for
one more question so my question for you
is there there's been a lot of work okay
I'm not a bronco fan okay my question is
about the changing demographics of the
customer base in the United States and
to what extent is walmart tracking that
and shifting the design of the stores
and the formats particularly with age
friendly design yeah i think there's
three or four components to your
question it's a very good question but
there's three or four different
components to it you've got the age
change the aging of the consumer you
also have a consumer that's now has a
smaller family unit so families are
smaller so the consumers aging families
are smaller the consumer is more diverse
in fact I was reading an article the
other day that the whole concept of
diversity is going to go away over time
because the consumer landscape will be
so diverse diverse won't even be
diversity won't even be thought of like
it is today you know the Anglo Caucasian
will no longer be the majority it may be
the largest minority but just another
minority so that's changing the other
thing is the physical side is changing
too because of the growth of
urbanization and more and more people
moving to urban centers versus being in
these rural centers and so you've got
all of those components of change I know
what we see is the consumer today does
not want to walk a two hundred and
twenty thousand square foot store they
want it smaller that store is too big
for them
and so that's why our super centers are
getting smaller that's why we're growing
smaller format stores it's also easier
to get real estate in metropolitan
markets with a smaller footprint so that
lends itself also to smaller so the
other components the aging demographic
and the smaller family size lends itself
to potentially smaller pack sizes you
know this size versus this size the
consumer may be more interested in that
and then from a demographic standpoint
also we've got to be better with our
store of the community so that the
merchandise that we're offering to the
consumer matches the ethnicities of
those consumers that shop that store and
so we've got to have a lot more
variation and the different types of
things I was in a store the other day
this is probably overkill but we had 46
different mustards now 46 different
mustards is probably too much but you
see that in sauces and spices and things
like that justin is huge offering now
and I think the Internet has brought
some of that on also as more and more
people get whatever they want or can
request through the internet and
customers have that mentality of I want
everything and we need to satisfy that
desire hmmm did anything she does thank
you good job thank you very good thank
you guys
nice to meet you I appreciate thanks for
your time oh thank you very much nice to
meet you and thank you guys also from
your questions